how did this unfold for you kevin with
with the rap career obviously
it took something devastating for mike
you know you know somebody killing this
pigeon
you know enough for him to discover you
know the sport of boxing
for you as a kid man what what what
brought you into to the rap game
it was an escape for me and i'ma say
i never said this in no interview no
podcast or anything like that
i grew up real real violent and real
aggressive
not because i wanted to be but i was
molested when i was a child
so i had this fear of being vulnerable
so i took all every kind of martial arts
you could take and
i even boxed i did everything and i
wanted to be the toughest person on
earth
but writing and making music was always
an escape for me
like i never had the like the nuts to
come out and say that
this is my first time saying this today
since i did but i know i know that i
know that route too
why do you think i became the meanest
[ __ ] on the planet
somebody did certain to me yeah so and i
didn't want to happen again
so i became this guy yeah
take it to the furthest extent yeah yes
sir that's my that's my story
that's after but it was really it was
really everything that i did even like
people say
like kevin gates he just killed i'm not
i'm not
but the reason i speak about it now
because i just released a mixtape like
maybe
maybe a few months ago and guys walk up
to me in the gym like bodybuilders
and just hug me and cry and be like man
i went through the same [ __ ] you went
through like
keep doing what you doing so i'm like i
guess i'm on the right path
yo you're really politic out there in
the music world man
i mean when we first started so who's
that that's kevin gates kevin gates i
thought you have a fancy rap name name
the king shabazz or something
it's kevin gates playing old kevin
it's all good yes you've had a lot you
know looking up your story man you've uh
you know you're you're muslim too on uh
yes
yeah the devoted as much as i can as
much as you can i guess
for everybody you know what i'm saying
mike like he's uh
he's in the game and it's uh god just
wants him to say
he you know me he's in control you know
god
elijah wants him to know that he follows
allah allah just wants to love him
that's all
allah knows what we do before we were
even born he knew we were going to do
what we're going to do what we do be
judged by the intentions of our heart
and our heart alone
you